and Melinda wast gave fans another look
at the size changing shenanigans of poor
words and men and added in more
characters more action and equal billing
for Evangeline Lily's was as you might
expect for a movie about characters that
shrink down to microscopic characters of
a classic sci-fi movie shout outs here
are even smaller details you may have
missed in ant-man
and the wasp here's the deal you just
give me the facts just facts only the
facts breathe focus keep it simple no no
no doubt no doubt
ex-con security solutions the plots of
ant-man and the wasp is focused on
saving Janet Van Dyne from the quantum
realm but we also see what Scott's been
doing since the last film he started a
small business with luison company
ex-con a security consulting service
it's a reference straight from 2015's up
Man comics series in which Scott Lang
starts a security consulting service
ant-man security solutions
the biggest difference besides the name
- Suffolk comics version features the
Grizzly a giant bear manic supervillain
as his business partner slash employee
he is hoping that this particular detail
somehow makes it into the next time man
movie as well
wish I had a suit even with like minimal
powers maybe even just the soup with no
powers who wouldn't want to see Michael
Pena suits up in a giant bear costume on
the big screen I see what you did there
early in the film Scott builds an
obstacle course for his daughter out of
carboard
a bit of father-daughter bonding might
be adorable but it also hides a
reference to one of Marvel's strangest
villains the orb in order to crack the
retinal scanner that Scott has assembled
Cassie has to put on a giant eyeball
mask which looks suspiciously similar to
the orb a Marvel super villain whose
head is a giant eyeball well it seemed
like a bit of a stretch the orb actually
became a pretty major player in the last
decade of Marvel Comics in 2014 the
original sin storyline he successfully
steals an eye from the cosmic deity The
Watcher forces dozens of heroes to
confront long buried secrets and even
becomes a pseudo watcher himself it's
Cassie's masca hints that there's
another enemy for the Avengers to fight
after Thanos has taken care of we'll
have to keep our eyes peeled magic man
Scott struggle to keep Cassie
entertained while he's under house
arrest involves more than just building
giant cardboard obstacle courses he also
becomes an expert at sleight of hand
- an online magic course it's no wonder
that Scott becomes pretty good at magic
since his online teacher is actually
played by an expert magician
Blake Voigt why Trey take a bite out of
it
[Music]
Hoyt has made a name for himself as a
magic consultant on movies like now you
see me if he contributes his expertise -
and fun on the wasp as well
he even cameos ascots online teacher
briefly visible while Scott and later
FBI agent Jimmy woo a learning close-up
magic you know what this means don't you
now Doctor Strange isn't the only magic
user in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
- earth has wizards no really small
details wall-sized changing was a big
part of the original ant-man the sequel
makes the Pym particles an even bigger
part of the story Hank Pym as a
laboratory that shrinks down into a
piece of luggage complete with a handle
and wheels for maximum convenience the
quantum tunnel that they construct -
safe Janet from the quantum realm is a
fun mix of low and high tech combining
intricate computer parts for small items
and large too much I like the idea that
Hank Pym is not Tony Stark it's not
super sleek high-tech it's sort of you
know couch together and and he uses a
lot of found object keep your eyes
peeled in the movie for trying to follow
you knobs to help calibrate Janet's
location giant bread clips holding wires
together and plenty of other enlarged
household objects used for the quantum
tunnel it might be true that one man's
trash is another man's treasure
but it's probably a bit more convenient
when the trash is expanded to giant size
the matrix Laurence Fishburne is an
accomplished actor who's appeared in
dozens of movies and well this but he's
arguably best known for playing Morpheus
the mysterious leader of the freedom
fighters and the matrix Fishburne's bill
foster doesn't share too many qualities
with the martial arts master Morpheus
but a man on the wasp still has a small
reference to Fishburne's most famous
role when Scott's Hank and hope go to
convince bill to help them track down
Pym stolen technology bill is teaching a
class on quantum entanglement and the
blackboard behind him is covered with
mathematical equations one equation
right next to Bill's head in the shot
even includes the word matrix as Keanu
Reeves neo would say whoa
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]